okay so now this presenter chat how can
i get rid of that
um you can minimize it there is a uh
little minus looking icon in the top
right of the presentation
got it i'm sorry could you start over
yeah give it just a few seconds and then
you can get started
hello welcome to my presentation on the
clinical scale production of
extracellular vesicles
in a hollow fiber bioreactor i'm john
cadwell
i'd like to take the mixner approach to
cell culture
it's important i think for you to
understand that cell culture is
a relatively new technique in the
laboratory first attempts at
culturing cells in vitro or in glass
outside of the body was by harrison in
1906
and he used frog neuronal implants on a
plasma clot
a three-dimensional cell culture matrix
subsequently we moved from glass into
plastic
now it wasn't until the late 50s that we
developed the gila cell line
we required proteolytic enzymes to make
for
single cell suspensions
[Music]
lavender flow hoods didn't come onto the
scene until the late 70s
scaling up of cell culture has always
been about more surface area
but fundamentally current
two-dimensional cell culture is
an inherently non-physiologic process we
are growing cells
sub-confluent non-porous two-dimensional
plastic discs
in the presence of fetal bovine serum
which in itself
is non-physiologic serum is plasma with
the clotting factors removed
the only time the cells will see serum
is in an activated state
so it's important to understand that
cell culture as practiced today
is inherently non-physiologic
all of these techniques to a greater
lesser degree will subject the cells to
what we call the feast or famine cycle
which means that glucose starts out high
lactate starts out low
there's this period of time that the
cells are attaching to the plastic
and starting to secrete some of their
own cytokines we call the lag phase
after lag phase glucose consumption will
increase
lactate production will increase the
cells at their optimum
density and homeostatic conditions for
only a short period of time
for optimum protein production ev
production and cell physiology
and then just when things are getting
good it's time to trypsinize everything
we have to split the cells
the reason that we split the cells is
that nutrients come from the top down
and the bottom layer cells do not get
gas and nutrients so that they die and
peel off and float away
so we must maintain the cells in a
sub-confluent monolayer culture
this again is inherently non-physiologic
cell culture conditions are constantly
changing the cells spend a very small
amount of time out of the total time and
culture
in their optimum homeostatic cell
culture conditions
hollow fiber is fundamentally different
from any other way of culturing cells
and it is a three-dimensional more
vivo-like way of growing
cells and it's based on the principle
that each one of these little hollow
fibers
is like a filter it's shaped like a
drinking straw
it's about 200 microns in diameter we
seal them in the ends
in this polycarbonate shell using a
polyurethane potting material
so that anything that goes from the ends
of the cartridges
necessarily goes to the insides of the
fiber
and typically we grow the cells on the
outside of the fiber
what we have done then is set up a
semi-permeable barrier
between where the media is flowing and
the cells are growing
it is a three-dimensional more in
vivo-like way of culturing cells
that has a profound effect on how the
cells behave in culture
this is just an illustration of what our
hollow fiber cartridge looks like
we have a loop of silicone tubing where
gas exchange takes place
we use a positive pressure displacement
pump there's a frictionless pump
frictionless pumping system so we don't
shed plastic off the pump tubing
and clog up the fibers
so a hollow fiber bioreactor a
three-dimensional capillary bioreactor
is fundamentally different from any
other way of growing cells in three
important ways
number one we have an extremely high
surface area to volume ratio
inside the cartridge just like we do in
vivo
so our standard cartridge is our c2011
cartridge
it has 4 000 square centimeters of
surface area
and a volume of 20 millimeters so we
basically have
200 square centimeters of surface area
per milliliter volume
this extremely high surface area volume
ratio is the only way
to culture cells at in vivo like cell
densities
1 to 2 times 10 to 8 cells per mil it is
the only way to culture cells
and a density which allows them to
control
and generate their own specific micro
environment
this is super important we'll talk about
that later
cells are bound to a porous support not
a non-porous 2d flask
this means that we never have to split
the cells and passage
passage number is irrelevant nutrients
come from the bottom
up just like they do in vivo so there's
a more and fever-like way of growing
cells
again we never have to split the cells
we've cultured glioma
cell line for over two years of
continuous culture
we've produced a hybrido for over a year
of continuous culture
with no change in antibody affinity and
affinity
lastly we control the molecular cutoff
this is a measurement of the
fiber pore size and the filter size
it is measured in daltons
we have a 5 000 and a 20 000
molecular cutoff available 5kd and 20kd
now i think it's very important to
understand and know fundamentally
exactly what a dalton is this is one of
my pet peeves
and it will be part of the continuing
medical education questions as part of
this
seminar just to show you how important i
think it is it's important to know that
a dalton is the mass of a hydrogen atom
it was first described by sir john
dalton in 1784
when he's a professor at cambridge
university so
nowadays nist likes to call it dalton 1
12th of the mass of the carbon atom
they want to relate everything to carbon
so when the aliens come we could talk to
them about
carbon and a dalton is 1 12 the mass
of a carbon atom so a hydrogen atom
is the smallest indivisible atomic unit
that you can have
just to keep things in perspective then
the antibody is the molecular weight of
around 147
000 bonds 147 kb
the average mass of amino acid is around
120.
so we can look at this and say okay igg
has about
1200 amino acids and it's important to
understand this also
in the context of an exosome vvs are
going to be anywhere from
60 to 120 nanometers in size
much larger than the antibond so an
antibody cannot cross the 20kb molecular
cutoff
and neither can an extracellular vessel
so this is a cute little video or a
positive pressure displacement pump it's
a frictionless pumping system
postal tile flow facilitates exchange
with nutrients and waste products
across the fiber cells are growing on
the outside of the fiber
nutrients and waste products can cross
the fiber the
product of interest cannot cross the
fiber we can simply harvest it by using
some syringes
and pulling out your product on a daily
basis
[Music]
so in the laboratory the system designed
to be very simple
temperature is controlled by the
incubator gas composition is controlled
by the incubator
it fits inside any standard incubator
we have a thin cord that goes through
the door for power it's not necessary to
run
anything through the back of the
incubator so we can maintain and
retain our co2 concentration in the
incubator
we work with the cartridge it's very
important to have good sterile technique
we must remember that pasteur was
correct life does not spontaneously
generate
all we're going to do on a daily basis
move it into the hood so in a laminar
flow hood
in a nice aseptic environment
maintenance is only going to take 15
minutes a day we want to measure the
glucose
the rate of glucose uptake i.e the
glucose uptake rate or gur
is going to be an indication of how many
cells we have in the cartridge
how happy the cells are and what's going
on so
as long as the glucose uptake rate is
either plateauing or increasing
the cells are very happy we
know from experience that a glucose
uptake rate of approximately one gram
per day
means that we have about
one times 10 to the night cells total in
the cartridge
we're going to harvest our product
harvest volumes be anywhere from
two milliliters on up to 60 milliliters
concentration of our secreted products
will be anywhere from 10
to 100 times higher than what you'll
have in a regular
bioreactor flask culture
so the fundamental advantages of fiber
cell culture
we have a concentrated product culturing
cells are very high densities
so that the concentrated product is not
crossing the fiber
will become anywhere from 10 to 100
times more concentrated
than what you'll find in regular flask
or spinner culture
because of the cell culture conditions
again the cells are high density they're
in
vivo like cell density they are able to
generate their own micro environment
this has the cells spending much more
time at their optimum
cell culture conditions as we saw in the
thesis famine diagram earlier
so because of these modern fever-like
cell culture conditions we can
demonstrate
uniform and complete post-translational
modifications
over several months of continuous
production and as we know
in the case of evs and exosomes cell
culture conditions will play
a key role in terms of how evs are
produced and their
activity we also see
low we'll use the term apoptosis
what this means is that because there's
no shear on the cells
and because of their cell culture
conditions
the cells will become necrotic
they'll die but they do not life
so we see much lower levels of
contamination with intracellular dna
membrane fragments host cell proteins
membrane fragments the platonic bodies
specifically
can interfere with exosome purification
so this is a very key feature of hollow
fiber cell culture this
low cell apoptosis
because of the high cell density we've
developed
and the generation of their own micro
environment by the cells
we have been able to develop a product
called cdmhd or chemically defined media
for high density culture the cell
culture conditions
found in a hollow fiber bioreactor are
different enough
and unique enough that we can
simplify and optimize a cell culture
media
to take advantage of these cell culture
conditions so
cdmhd is a serum replacement that
is simplified it's basically
micronutrients
extra amino acids buffering capacity
some other
small ingredients all chemically defined
there is
protein free animal component free
sorry protein-free animal component
and uh specifically optimized blind
foreign
yeah we could take a quick break um and
i can
make sure to edit this portion out um
i can start over with this slide this
guy outside mode alone
i'll shut the door and get her out of
here okay
give me one sec i'm just going to make a
quick note yeah do you want to just pick
up this slide up should be fine with me
yeah slide 10 right
sorry about that i guess that's a
consequence of it now this guy that's
outside it's moving the lawn is that
causing too much noise because he's
going to be done in
a few minutes no i actually can't hear
him at all
okay good all right um so we can go
ahead and start off
again with slide 10 whenever you're
ready just give it a short few seconds
and then you can get started again
so the advantages of hollow fiber cell
culture are as follows
we have a concentrated product product
is secreted by a large number of cells
and is not able to cross the fiber so it
will be concentrated anywhere from 10
to 100 times higher than what you find
from conventional cell culture methods
we've also seen uniform complete
post-translational modifications
because the cells are high density they
are
creating their own micro environment and
they are spending more time extended
periods of time in their optimum
homeostatic cell culture conditions
required
for optimum protein production and cell
physiology
as we know evs are going to be a direct
reflection of the conditions of the cell
culture at the time
it's very important to have uniform and
homeostatic cell culture conditions
for optimum production of recombinant
proteins and extracellular vesicles
we can demonstrate uniform and complete
post-translational modifications of
monoclonal antibodies
with no change in glycosylation patterns
affinity and avidity for more than six
months
continuous culture we have also seen
low apoptosis what we see is
cell death cell necrosis but the cells
don't lyse
so it's not unusual to see
large numbers of intact dead cells in a
harvest from a hollow fiber cartridge
we're preferentially pulling out the
dead cells when we do harvest
the important thing is that we see less
contamination with host cell proteins
with the intracellular dna and most
importantly membrane fragments
so uh this is not going to be an issue
all right i'm sorry i've got a delivery
that comes in we're gonna have to pick
this up again
in just a second
foreign
good i'm sorry that's a wine shipment so
i have to sign for it
no worries all right
i've made a note this is uh still slide
10 correct
yes okay all right give it just another
few seconds and then you can get started
so the advantages of hollow fiber cell
culture are as follows
we have a concentrated product product
is concentrated
by the molecular cut off of the fiber
remains in the extra capillary space
along with cells where it becomes very
highly concentrated and we can just
harvest it out every day we see uniform
and complete post-translational
modifications
this is because the cells are creating
their own microenvironment
and are spending much more time in their
optimum homeostatic
physiologic cell culture conditions for
optimum protein production
and cell physiology
we see low apoptosis the cells die the
necrotic
but they don't split open so it's not
unusual to see
large numbers of dead cells intact dead
cells
in your harvested product but we see
significantly less contamination
with intracellular dna whole cell
proteins and most importantly membrane
fragments
we've developed our protein-free media
cdmhd
chemically defined media for
high-density culture
the cell culture environment found in a
homo fiber bioreactor
is fundamentally different from any
other way of growing cells
this makes it possible for us to
specifically simplify
and optimize the media that we use in
conjunction with these bioreactors
so cdmhd is chemically defined protein
free
animal component free and cgmp compliant
one of the things that's important to me
about cdmhd is that it's
not just a product it is a direct
manifestation of the different cell
culture conditions
found in a 3d hollow fiber bioreactor
because cdmac does not work in flask
culture
cd media does cdmhd does not work in
standard
cell culture systems the cells must be
at a higher density they need to be
generating
their own microenvironment so the cells
need to be at least five times seven to
seven cells per ml
or higher in order for cdhd to be able
to support their growth
so we can see over long-term culture
consistency of production in terms of
post-translational modifications
protein purification and eevee
production over time
so of course we all know what exosomes
are just a brief review
they're small particles uh derived in
biological fluids they're anywhere from
30 to 120 nanometers in size
they have micro rna that may contain
their therapeutic
activity inside vesicles they have
proteins on the exterior
they're targeting proteins in my mind my
own personal
theory and hypothesis is that
evs exist to protect the microrna
inside the vesicle because you don't
want to have free rna floating around
inside your biological fluids
and we need to be able to direct them to
specific areas for them to exert their
activity so
evs are targeted cell regeneration
vectors that can be used for many
different therapeutic purposes
so this is a reminder of the standard
methods for producing evs at least up
until now
we utilize uh 2d plastic class we've
already discussed how non-physiologic
that is
and we'll take out the serum so get the
cells to confluence in the serum
containing media
we remove the serum serum contains a
significant amount of
endogenous suction center vesicles we
want to get rid of those and not have
them interfere
so we'll put them into protein-free
media serum-free media for about
48 hours and then collect evs under
these conditions so you can imagine
just how non-physiologic even in the
absence of serum that these kinds of
conditions for ev
production are just a little experiment
that we did
in house we found that if we use cdhd
under these conditions
then we can significantly enhance ev
production for themselves in this
protocol
however and it's still not very
efficient and keep in mind that
10 to the night cells generates a lot of
plastic trash
and in this case this is just an example
of what it takes to expand a t-75 flask
up to tendonized cells which is going to
be about 50 t25 flask
so it generates a lot of garbage so
there must be a better way of doing
things
so the advantages of how fiber
bioreactors for ev production
are that large numbers of cells can be
cultured in a small space
our standard cartridges c2011 can
support
10 to the ninth cells our larger
cartridge which we're going to be
scaling up to in the next few weeks in
our own lab the c2018
can support one to three to one to three
to five times ten to the ten cells it's
quite a range i know
but somewhere between one and five times
ten to the ten total cells
and a volume of sixty millions uh the
secreted exosomes will be significantly
concentrated
we're also finding that harvest
frequency has a significant impact on
the efficiency
of extracellular vesicle collection so
we're looking to optimize that
and i'll give you more data on that in a
minute
so we know we can do continuous
production many cell types over many
months
so we can set up a continuous production
scheme
with a 3d holofiber my reactor
we have protocols where we've used serum
to support the cells
we can put serum into the circulating
media through the ics or intracapillary
space
but the factors in serum that support
cell growth
can cross the fibers the extracellular
vesicles the endogenous extracellular
vesicles that we don't want
cannot cross the fiber so we can safely
use
serum in the uh to support the cells if
we need to
however we found that most cell types
as long as we can get the density up to
10.8 cells per mil
we can utilize cg cbmhd which of course
is going to be ev-free
and it is fully cgmp compliant
the mscs mesophyll stem cells we work
with a lot
um i'm not going to go into a whole
other another seminar to talk about mscs
but
briefly found that uh mesocommon stem
cells regardless of their source
don't seem to proliferate too much
unless they're under special conditions
i believe that this is just a function
of mscs and how they behave in needle
but part of the definition of mscs these
are common stem cells is that they
attach to plastic and proliferate in a
3d environment they do not appear to
proliferate
this is both good news and bad news bad
news is we need a lot of cells
to see the cartridge good news is that
the cells aren't proliferating
they're not differentiating so i'll show
that we've been able to maintain mscs
for
45 to 60 days continuous culture
harvesting exosomes
all along
just some of our initial work showed
that uh with
the human adipose derived mesochinal
stem cells
um there are one c201 bioreactor
um harvesting once a week we are
generating
about we'll just say nine times 10 to
the 11th we'll fudge it up to 10 of the
12 evs
and this equals in terms of our control
540 t225 flash
ev production is going to vary a lot in
terms of our comparisons depending on
the cell time
depending on the harvesting frequency
and many other factors but this was a
direct comparison that we did one of our
early ones
and in terms of bioactivity we can
demonstrate that
we did see enhanced wound healing
activity produced by these
exosomes uh in this this rat wound
healing model
um but more interestingly
as collaborators of ours we worked with
this was a way to make uh
exercise or vesicles inexpensive enough
that they can be used
in a commercial product so in point of
fact we have this product produced
called
exophase there's an exosome based facial
moisturizer and they've got some some uh
data on this uh 95 reduction wrinkles
uh skin luminescence some
19 18 acceleration cell renewal
so we've got lots of nice data from this
commercial product that utilizes
our system to produce uh commercially
viable extracellular vesicles in this
case they're called smarticles
this is just another example from one of
our researchers
that's been working from from working
with us from switzerland
and basically what it's showing for a
small cartridge this is our c2025d
uh 450 square centimeters in surface
area
that we get cumulative linear growth of
the evs
and linear production of evs over time
this is bone marrow msc from human
umbilical cord msc
in this particular case i think we found
perhaps so this is
uh data that i have that has been
published
but there's still some some uh
data that i still need to get from them
but in this case we can see that
they seeded two times ten to the eighth
mscs and they utilized the cell growth
factor that seems to have gotten
themselves proliferate
in any event they seeded ten times two
times ten of the eight cells
um and we consumed uh 200 mix of glucose
per day we expect
and we see that they they over time they
did expand
and we were able to culture these mscs
for 44 days
before things started to drop off but
this is going to be important a minute
basically they compared 2d
msc exercise vesicles in terms of cell
surface
markers with the 3d
evs and the cell surface markers and
here we're just showing consistency
between day 23
and day 55 of culture which to me is
important because
evs remained uniform and consistent over
time
even though the cell population started
to diminish
so i think that this is showing that the
physiology of the cells
was still the optimum for ev production
here we've just got a comparison in
terms of particle size
and western blot analysis of the 2d
versus 3d evs in this case we can see
that the 3d ev is equal to about 225
t225 flash
now our poster from uh international
society of extracellular vesicles
we did in conjunction with laura perrin
she had some
human amniotic uh fluid stem cells
that we cultured in our little cartridge
um and produced evs for her
and most surprisingly we found that
regardless of the harvesting interval
whether it was one hour
two hours or every 24 hours ev
concentration was pretty much the same
uh at the level of around uh two times
ten to the eighth four times ten minutes
two point eight times ten to the tenth
4 times 10 to the 10th hourly harvest
or if we can harvest it over a day
concentration is the same
so there's a significant either
inhibition
of ev secretion based on external ev
concentration
or um uh inhibition of secretion
based on this concentration so it's
either inhibition to reuptake or
inhibition secretion based on
the high concentration of evs in the
extra capillary space
um here's some of our primary data just
showing
the same particle size distribution
the cv numbers tetraspan
analysis showed the weaker expression of
some of the other cb
markers we're not exactly sure what's
the reason for that because the
bioactivity was actually
enhanced in terms of both
fibronectin co-precipitation and in vivo
injection to alport mice
showing amelioration of protein urea
based upon eevee therapy of the kidneys
so the advantages here we got
demonstrated enhanced bioactivity in
many different publications
rheumatically mammalian secretory system
long-term homeostasis and cell culture
environment
now the most important thing to me is
going to be that
many grant applications are being
criticized because
there's just not the capability and
capacity to produce the number of evs
required for clinical trials or
individual animal studies
my my feeling is that hollow fiber
does actually produce the numbers of evs
required
for clinical translation and we have a
project ongoing in our lab
we're just starting up where we're going
to try to demonstrate the production of
10 to the 15th
or gram quantities of evs and if we look
at
other comparative methods that i pulled
out of some journal articles
and some presentations rooster bio is
promoting a micro carrier method for
producing large numbers
of evs 10 to the 13th uvs
um so that would actually require
to get the 10 of the 15s would take 100
runs
of this bioreactor to produce 10 of the
15th no evs
quantum has published some data showing
that they get 10 to the 13th
in 1500 mils of supernatant
and we need to again run 100 runs of
their system in order to get to 10 to
the 15th
um my expectation is that
we'll set up a cartridge and be able to
generate
10 to the 14th evs in our product
for under in a month for under 30 000
cost now what would a system like this
look like just to look into the future
maybe
a little bit this is a diagram of
a closed automated cgmp compliant
modifier bioreactor system that could be
used to produce
10 of the 14 to 10 to 15 evs or more
so we can see that the holofiber by
reactor is
the most evolved way the most viva-like
way
of culturing cells and i see great
applications for this
both in terms of producing eds under
physiologic conditions and producing evs
in quantities sufficient for clinical
translation
so again i'm john cadwell with fibrocell
systems thanks so very much for your
time
okay great job we are all set so pretty
much from here i will do some editing on
the front back ends as well as
slide 10 and then get your presentation
ready for the event in a few weeks
sorry about the dog and sorry about the
one no worries at all um if you have any
questions that come up feel free to
reach out but if not
um i will send you a preview link once
your presentation is ready
okay great all righty have a good recipe
john bye-bye